this helmet camera footage was taken
during a raid in uruzgan province in
afghanistan in 2012
and obtained by the four corners program
of australian broadcaster
abc the unarmed man is shot three times
at close range
killed by an australian special forces
soldier
a small number of people acted in an
aberrant way
that is impacted on families in
afghanistan
and elsewhere and they should be held
accountable
an independent inquiry investigated 55
incidents involving australian special
forces in afghanistan that allegedly
took place between 2005 and 2016
including accusations of unlawful
killings of prisoners
and civilians australians were deployed
alongside u.s and allied forces
following the 2001
september 11 attacks in new york the
inquiry began
in early 2016 and has been conducted
behind
closed doors since then it was
instigated by
a commander of special forces and
supported by the australian defense
force
but as it's progressed the alleged
incidents have become
a highly charged public debate
admiral chris barry a former chief of
the australian defense force
says it's important the public is
informed about the nature of the alleged
defenses
and any possible trials only in that way
will we be able to to show
people that we are serious about being a
force for good
and secondly when people don't do it as
we expect we're going to do something
about it
the international criminal court is also
investigating whether war crimes were
committed in afghanistan
by the taliban the afghan military and
u.s forces opposed by the u.s government
president donald trump has sanctioned
some icc staff i think we should be
encouraged by the process that australia
is undertaking here
but you know there's more that needs to
be done and we need to keep monitoring
and to ensure that that process
is actually effective and genuine more
than 26 000 australians served in
afghanistan over 13 years
the nation's longest military
involvement in any war
the question in australia is what impact
will the results of this inquiry have on
people's perceptions of the conflict
and those who took part nikola gage
al-jazeera
canberra joining me now is roger
shanahan who is a former australian army
officer and a research fellow at the
loewy institute for international policy
joins me now via skype from sydney
always good to have you on the program
mr shanahan i mean it's taken four years
to get this report
potentially uh to this stage where its
findings will be released on thursday
but surely the battle begins now from
all sides about prosecutions and defense
of what transpired in afghanistan
absolutely and this is one of the uh one
of those significant issues this
administrative inquiry has taken four
years
um the report has been eagerly awaited
but
really this is simply the start of the
next phase the public is going to be
informed about the findings of the
report
and then the legal processes take over
from here and that is going to take
several years to come yet
in your opinion um did the australian
armed forces serve impeccably and
impartially in afghanistan
you too served in afghanistan did you
ever hear
of these sorts of rumors or whispers
that
officers or uh those
on the front line acted unprofessionally
in any way
well australia had a had a policy
of uh doing inquiries as did a number of
other countries
into accusations or instances of
civilian casualties
i myself did several of those
so there was a pretty robust
procedure about investigating
accusations of civilian casualties
but the reality is that if you have
special forces who operate in
disaggregated groups
and incidents happen well away from
prying eyes then you can't
understand everything that goes on such
a complex battlefield so
overall certainly there was a robust
procedure for civilian casualties but
no process or procedure is going to
obviously encapsulate every incidence of
this happening
when you talk about reports like this so
when we sort of discuss them
on programs like ours how fine a
tightrope are the australian military
walking in terms of trying to be open
and transparent
without sort of leaving personnel left
open and hung out to dry
yeah again this is a really interesting
issue
we're talking about people who are
potentially in breach of the laws of
armed conflict but they've done multiple
rotations
uh undertaking high intensity uh
operations in a very complex
uh battle space so we have to
understand the context in which they
operate but at the same time
there's 30 000 australian military
personnel
operated in afghanistan everybody has
taught about laws of armed conflict
everybody understands what their ethical
obligations are and the reality is
if there are people who have overstepped
those bounds and committed
committed crimes then they need to be
held to account so
certainly it's a complex issue to
inquire into but it doesn't mean that
you shouldn't
do that inquiry how long do you think
the process is going to take really once
the report is unveiled to then
sort of hear uh those that all the
interested parties that
have something to say about what the
report says those that want to agree
with it or disagree with it
and therefore the legal uh process that
may follow for those that want to get
justice
absolutely this is going to be one of
the issues there is going to be
a significant debate i expect over the
next few days in australia but then the
issue about the legal processes start
and even if we start from uh tomorrow
after the report is written it's going
to take years for those
investigations and then briefs of
evidence to be given to the director of
public prosecutions and whether they
decide to prosecute
so the court system is going to take
years and we're already looking at some
incidents
that happened eight to ten years ago so
we
we then have that tricky uh issue of are
we going to
go to court and if we do what is the
practical implications of trying
uh potential crimes that happen 15 16 17
years prior to that it's going to be
a very interesting um issue
to be debated over the next few years
and the legalities of it are going to be
equally
fascinating i'm sure we'll be returning
to the subject in the future at some
stage i'm sure roger shanahan from the
loewy institute
in sydney thanks so much for joining us
sir
my pleasure